we have lost a few people
and it's been hard because
we have cared for them for so long
and we
truly do love them and we're all
devastated and we just miss him so much
he was such
he was a wonderful person you see
that all these deaths are preventable
they're preventable
and people just don't pay attention we
can see the morgue outside of our window
and i feel heartbroken
i just feel heartbroken
good evening i'm mehdi hassan welcome to
the show
2020 has been defined by some of the
biggest stories
of our lifetimes the nationwide
uprisings against racial injustice to
2020
election and the defeated president's
attempt to try and overturn the result
but no story has been bigger
darker deadlier than the global
coronavirus pandemic
and because of our government botched
response
nowhere has it hit harder than here in
the united states of america
we have four percent of the world's
population but almost 19
of the world's covert deaths it's hard
to get our head around these numbers we
become
numb to the death toll when we see it in
the hundreds of thousands
rising inexorably by the day for a while
now
i haven't been able to get that old
saying attributed to joseph stalin
out of my head one death is a tragedy a
million is a statistic
we have been overwhelmed by statistics
by numbers by
casualty figures in the six and seven
digits
so tonight in a special episode of this
show and as this year
finally comes to a close i want to pay
tribute
to the individuals the stories the
sacrifices behind those numbers
through the lives of 50 people 50
lost souls because talking about
individuals
real identify real identifiable people
is the only way to truly make sense
of this tragedy and understand the
unbearable loss and suffering
that so many have witnessed and endured
this year
and are still enduring president-elect
joe biden a man who knows all too much
grief and loss perhaps put it best
during the first presidential debate
look you folks at home how many of you
get up this morning
and had an empty chair at the kitchen
table because someone died at covet
how many of you were in a situation
where you lost your mom or dad and you
couldn't even speak to them you had
a nurse holding a phone up so you could
in fact say goodbye
one death is a tragedy so let's go one
person at a time
i hope you'll join with me as we do
something very different tonight over
the course of this hour
but something so necessary so important
acknowledging just a few of those lives
we have lost
this year let's start where else with
one of our health care workers
someone from the ranks of the brave
doctors nurses paramedics those
brave men and women who have risked
everything this year to fight the
pandemic on the front lines
often without proper protection without
proper ppe
and often giving their lives to save the
lives of their patients
people like dr rebecca shadowen a 62
year old doctor in kentucky
infectious disease specialist who pushed
hard to get her local community to take
the virus seriously
just because we're loosening up our
society to try to become functional
again doesn't mean that we stop
all of the precautions that we've been
doing those are what has saved lives
and until we have treatment vaccine it's
the only thing that's going to save
lives
later that month she contracted the
virus herself and she was
in and out of hospital but after dealing
with complications from the virus
including
abdominal bleeding and weakened lungs dr
shadow and died on september the 11th
surrounded by her husband
and two children kentucky governor andy
beshear called her a
frontline hero saying he was heartbroken
if you could save the life of another
person without harming your own
would you shadow and posted online back
on march the 13th
but the doctor herself went further she
saved the lives
of other people while also giving up
her own as did adeline fagin a 28 year
old resident ob gyn in texas
who contracted covid in early july and
spent two months in hospital before
passing away
from the disease she died september the
19th her sister says adeline ended up
refusing sorry reusing her n95 mask
reusing it wearing the same one for
weeks
and weeks in new jersey dr priya khanna
43 year old nephrologist
died from covid on april the 13th her
seventy-year-old father retired surgeon
dr
satyanda khanna passed away from the
same disease just eight days later
same thing happened in florida too in
june both dr carlos vallejo
a 57 year old doctor of internal
medicine and his father dr
jorge vallejo an 89 year old retired
gynecologist
were hospitalized with covid they died
just a few weeks apart
dr james goodrich 73 years old a
pediatric neurosurgeon
famous for separating conjoined twins
died in march from covert having
continued to see patients at his new
york medical center till
the very end dr frank gabrin 60
a two-time cancer survivor who's
believed to be the first er doctor
to die in this country died from the
coronavirus
on march the 31st dr carlos
aragopresa a critical care pulmonologist
who
literally slept in his hospital so he
could be near his coveted patients
24 7 and yet he himself succumbed to
covert at the age of 51
earlier this month i honestly don't
think that i have
really come to accept you know like i
feel like i
i haven't reached the level of
acceptance that he's
gotten for real his partner
paige king says she remembers asking him
if he was worried he might get covered
himself
from one of his patients i'm not afraid
dr arahu praiser replied
i was born for this let's bring in dr
craig spencer he's the director of
global health and emergency medicine
at new york presbyterian hospital he was
also one of the first americans
to contract ebola back in 2014.
dr spencer thanks for joining us on the
show dr carlos arahu prasad who i just
mentioned there
he said i was born for this and a lot of
doctors have spent their entire lives
preparing studying getting ready to take
care of people
but what doctors in america prepared for
this level of suffering of what is
basically now
mass death i remember really early on in
march when we were starting to see a lot
of patients and a lot of people dying
here in new york city and i had
colleagues called me every single day
who said
you know i'm not sure that this is what
i signed up for many people
worried that we didn't have the right
skills or the right you know protective
equipment to take care of patients
all throughout the city and then now all
throughout the country i think all of us
are happy to take care of whoever comes
through that door but we were really
worried not only for our patients on how
we could best
treat them but how we could protect
ourselves and what we've seen
since is a lot of healthcare providers a
lot of nurses doctors respiratory
technicians
who've not only taken care of people
when they're dying and seen so many
families sob over facetime videos
but have lost their colleagues and their
friends themselves the same people
they've been working alongside for years
or decades
and that's been one of the hardest parts
of this
yes i can't imagine how hard it has been
for people on the front line just those
of us watching
uh our hearts ache and it's not just
your patience of course that you have to
worry about
it's each other you have lost colleagues
too to this virus haven't
you yeah i have i've lost
a few um one of the first
people that we lost one of our nursing
coordinators who was infected
during that early surge at the end of
march and was on a ventilator in the
same hospital
where he had worked for nearly two
decades romy was
a fantastic nurse a wonderful soul
someone that was always willing to go
the extra mile to take care of patients
and as we saw with so many other nurses
and other people who were on the front
lines
so you know taking care of so many
patients and doing everything they can
to save lives um unfortunately so many
of them paid with their own
and romy was was one of those who came
out of retirement
to be back in the front lines and
unfortunately lost his likelihood
yeah that's a amazing aspect to his
story that he didn't even need to be
there he had actually retired he had
done his duty he'd played his
role worked hard for many years but he
came out of retirement
because he saw the crisis on his
doorstep in a city
astonishing it was all hands on deck
honestly you know
we had people come in from all over the
country remember we had people
from the southwest and from from all
over to help us during that initial
surge
and you know some of the people who saw
what was happening came out of
retirement put in extra hours did
everything that they could
to to take care of others and at the
same time unfortunately just by
the nature of this virus and how it
transmits so many of them were infected
themselves and yeah you know we're still
dealing with this tool we're losing
health care providers every day
we are and it's such a preventable
tragedy uh that's part of what makes it
even more tragic than it should be
and there's not just a death from covid
there's doctors who are unable to simply
cope
with the stress and the trauma that
they're being forced to endure there are
people taking their own lives as well i
believe
yeah there absolutely are we
unfortunately lost one of our good
friends and
and our colleagues dr lorna breen um
earlier this year who
herself had survived govid and later
died by suicide
and since then we've been doing
everything that we can
to try to really highlight the mental
strain that this has had
on providers all over the country but
also
a lot of the issues around providers
being able to seek
mental health care there are a lot of
restrictions and limitations in terms of
concern about our licensing and whether
there'll be
you know some repercussions if providers
seek mental health assistance which is
just completely unacceptable and we need
to change
that we need to change the stigma around
mental health care for providers and i
think that covet
has shown this and dr lorna breen's
story and really her
her her heroic work um
has shown us that we absolutely need to
change the stigma around mental health
care especially amongst healthcare
providers
and one last quick question right now
new york where you are
as bad as it was in the spring but it's
pretty bad again
isn't it even as the new year is about
to start
absolutely you know look obviously on
the country scale we had the deadliest
day from covid yesterday
and sure new york doesn't look as bad as
it did in march and in april
but we've been comparing everything to
march and april for so long
that i think we're overlooking the fact
that march and april were absolutely
horrible
but we have doubled the number of
hospitalizations that we had in april
and in july
we have 120 000 people that are
hospitalized
and the worst days of this pandemic are
still in front of us
it's great we have a vaccine and there
is light at the end of the tunnel
that tunnel is extremely long and the
light at the end of that tunnel
is very faint so we need everyone to
continue
to to be careful and to keep doing the
things we've been asking for so long
we'll get to the end of this but we're
not there yet and
we need your help
we do indeed uh dr craig spencer thank
you so much for your time stay safe
it isn't just doctors of course of the
health care workers who are believed to
have died since the start of the
pandemic
more than 200 of them were nurses
according to a report
by national nurses united in september
people like jeanette williams parker 48
years old a nurse
in west virginia who died from covid in
the hospital where she worked in
september she's
survived by her fiance and her 18 year
old daughter who is herself
a nursing student 54 year old helen
bowdy
a registered nurse in washington dc who
dreamt of opening
up her own nursing home by the time she
was hospitalized with covert 19 she was
too weak to lift her arm
for a virtual handshake with her
daughter on facetime
70 year old iris maida retired in
january after a 35-year career as a
registered nurse
in august she came back to work to help
teach nurses as her way of contributing
to the fight against the coronavirus but
in october her family believes she
contracted covert while teaching
and last month she passed away then
there are the paramedics people like 48
year old sean matthews
nicknamed the selfie king who died from
covid
on november the second paul carey a
firefighter paramedic came out of
retirement
like so many others and drove an
ambulance from denver to new york when
it was being
overwhelmed by the virus in the spring
kerry died on april 30th at 66 years old
nearly 2 000 miles from home doing the
job he loved
but it's not just doctors nurses
paramedics
we often forget those other workers who
keep our hospitals running
unsung heroes like fall nice sheer adams
49 years old her sister says she cleaned
the room of a covered patient on april
the third
she had no mask no ppe within three
weeks she was hospitalized by may 16th
she had passed away from covet herself
seventy-year-old
irizmaldo castiblanco cleaned the room
of a suspected
covert patient at the start of march
days later his son a paramedic
called an ambulance for his father by
the end of the month he was gone
without the bravery and self-sacrifice
of our health co-workers especially
those who went into battle against the
virus in the early days
without the proper equipment and
protections that they deserved
without them it is no exaggeration to
say that the death toll might be
5 10 even 20 times higher than it
already is
we owe them everything and through it
all
health care workers have also sought to
lift spirits
this is how the staff at a doyletown
pennsylvania nursing home
has been trying to keep hope alive
throughout 2020
with a weekly dance party residents can
join in from the doorways of their room
and when we return we'll talk more about
nursing homes
and coronavirus there back after this
the ideal of the nuclear family mother
father two and a half kids
is a very modern concept across cultures
and across history
extended families have shared their
daily lives
grandma and grandpa haven't lived out
their final years
in a nursing home but a two breadwinner
household especially in the u.s
elder care as well as child care well
those are often
outsourced 2020 has showed us the limits
of that arrangement and nowhere has the
coronavirus been more deadly
than in nursing homes as of earlier this
month 39
of us covert deaths have been in nursing
homes four
out of every 10 people killed a shocking
new report from the aarp
blames poor government oversight a lack
of accountability across the industry
among other factors for those deaths the
study says many of these deaths were
preventable
and families are rightly angry the
children of jack
rhoda anita mayfield and ruth irene
carell
all praised the nurses who cared for
their parents in their final days
praised them for showing compassion it's
management at the homes
they died at in texas that they fault
management is the one that needs to be
punished in my book one daughter says
because they're the ones that dictated
what the employees do and look what
happened
there's been a lot of lives lost the
family of k
cows in central new york says they only
found out she died of covid
when the funeral home called to ask what
they'd like them to do
with her body at the new jersey nursing
home with the highest
death rate in the country it's hard to
know how many residents actually died of
covert according to the wall street
journal
that number is a hundred and one though
many were never tested
the children of eloise franco william
prendergrast frank vela
howard cognac senior charles van de pal
and joan williams
brought photos with them when they
protested outside that home
in october they want answers and so does
jamie worthy who watched her sister kim
mccoy warford
die in april on video at a nursing home
outside pittsburgh
she and more than a dozen other families
are now suing the facility for what they
cite
as reckless handling of the outbreak by
management
in a statement the brighton
rehabilitation and wellness center
denied the allegations
and said it worked closely to follow the
guidance of government health officials
that facility has also been under
federal and state investigations for
criminal neglect
during this pandemic jamie joins me now
jamie thank you so much for coming on
the show
i'm so sorry for your loss uh thank you
thank you and i was hoping you could
share i was hoping you could share
your story with us of your older sister
kim who died i believe on april the 18th
she was 64 years old tell us about her
um kim was a vibrant
big sister there's 11 years age
difference between kim and myself so
she was more like a second mother
growing up
kim was vibrant she was loving she was
full of life
and she ended up at brighton wellness
due to she was 57 years old when she
entered into the facility so she was not
elderly by any means
she had been there for seven years she
had early
onset dementia and was a patient
at brighton kim was a mother she's a
sister
she's a daughter um she was
looking at her picture it's just so sad
um
she was everything that we could imagine
um of being a big sister to our family
yeah it's horrible that such things have
happened this year and
jamie she she was 64.
you and 14 other families i know of the
residents there have filed a lawsuit
against the rehabilitation center saying
it
recklessly and intentionally disregarded
covert 19 procedures
can you tell us a little bit about what
happened with your sister how she was
treated
um well i went to go see kim at the end
of
february kim was fine
a couple weeks later we received a phone
call from the facility
saying that the facility was going to be
locked down
we couldn't go in to see her anymore my
sister was non-verbal and she was
non-ambulatory so it was very hard for
me
to speak with kim to find out what was
going on
the nurses and the aides at the facility
was truly my eyes and my ears
i received a phone call the end of march
that kim was running a fever
a few days late they said that there was
nothing to worry about
um that she would be fine they were
going to do a bedside x-ray
a few days later i received another
phone call saying she had spiked the
fever
and that they wanted to take her to the
emergency room
um kim was taken to the emergency room
we couldn't go with her she was by
herself
she went back to brighton
after they said they tested her for
covenant and they said she was negative
nothing we never had any results a few
days later i got another phone call
saying that kim
um was running another fever
and they were taking her back they took
her back
to the facility this time they kept her
overnight
and then they called me around six a.m
in the morning and said that she was
going to be admitted
we received a phone call from kim's pcp
not from the facility but from her pcp
um asking us had anyone made us aware
that kim was in a room with the first
person diagnosed with covid
at brighton wellness keep in mind kim
has
three roommates at that time there were
four to a room
um and i said no no one had told us that
and they said yes that she had been
exposed
and they were testing her we received a
phone call
saying that she was um positive and that
they were going to keep her for a few
days at this time brighton was saying
that you know they had a special unit
for them um
and that when she was transferred back
she would go to this special unit
there was no special unit can return
right back to the same floor
to the same room um that she had been on
um though it was the same nurses that i
was talking to
prior for the last seven years um that
was taking care of kim
when she went back to the facility they
had told her she turned the corner she
was doing well
they but then we received a phone call
after they said she was well and she was
found unresponsive
and she as you describe
what she as you described you know
getting coveted in that home
dying there away from you you not being
able to be there must have been
so hard for you uh and now uh you know
there's her death there's the lawsuit i
believe there's also the fact that you
your son and your husband all now have
covert right now under quarantine
i can't imagine how hard this year has
been for you
it's been really hard not being able to
give her a proper burial
having to wait 30 days
to even have a memorial service for her
and it's really sad right now because we
are
like i put on a good face today for this
interview
but my husband and my son were all
suffering
and to know that my sister went through
this
and wasn't able to tell anyone how she
felt or
to have anyone help her she couldn't cry
out to anyone to say you know the body
aches and and
the headaches and so this has really
been a year for us
well i'm truly hoping that 2021 is a
better year for you and your family
jamie
um i'm so sorry you've had to go through
this this year and i really appreciate
you taking time out for us um my
condolences again and i hope you and
your family get well
soon thank you so much
when the coronavirus began raging around
the globe
tom hanks and rita wilson were the first
celebrities
to announce they had the disease and for
many it was a watershed moment because
if the oscar-winning actor could
contract covert 19 well anyone could get
it couldn't they
hanks and wilson thankfully survived
their bout with the illness but many
other luminaries
weren't as lucky broadway actor nick
cordero died this summer
after a harrowing months-long fight with
covert 19.
he was only 41 years old country music
star charlie pride died earlier this
month in dallas
he was the son of sharecroppers and
became a pro baseball player
and the first black member of the
country music hall of fame
hall of fame pitcher tom seaver was the
leader of the 1969 miracle mets
championship team who went on to win
more than 300 games he passed away this
year
roy horn was one half of the las vegas
stage duo
siegfried and roy he died earlier this
month
grammy winning singer songwriter john
prine died in april from covid
musician adam schlesinger died in april
age 52 he was a member of the band
fountains of wayne
and emmy and an emmy-winning songwriter
of the tv show
my crazy ex-girlfriend chef chef floyd
cardoz was the founding chef
of tabla restaurant in new york and won
top chef masters
he died in march from covert at the age
of 59.
ellis masalis jazz pianist and patriarch
of the musical masalis family
died in april in his beloved new orleans
last week
his son winton masalas one of the
country's top jazz performers
surprised a young and talented jazz
performer named evan sherman
on a street corner in new york let's
listen to some of mr marsalis's legacy
as we go to this short break
in a year a decade full of political
strife
coronavirus is above all that no not the
government response to the pandemic that
has been and continues to be a disaster
i'm talking about the virus itself which
does not discriminate
based on age or ethnicity or what
political party you belong to
it simply does not care late last night
we learned that a congressman elect from
louisiana
died from covert 19 luke letlow was only
days away from being sworn in
former republican presidential candidate
herman cain died this summer after a
battle with coverty
he attended a masculist trump rally in
tulsa oklahoma
less than two weeks before his diagnosis
annie glenn was the widow of astronaut
and democratic united states senator
john glenn
she was a noted advocate for
communications disorders
she was she died in may at age 100 at a
nursing home
in minnesota south dakota republican
lawmaker bob glanza was one of the first
people in the state
to become infected he died in april
minnesota republican state senator jerry
ralph died earlier this month he and a
number of other lawmakers became
infected after attending a post-election
party
republican dick hinch was found dead at
home only one week after accepting
a unanimous nomination to be new
hampshire's house speaker
the coroner the coroner found he died
from covert 19.
and alice guzman of san antonio texas
had two
stepsons working in the highest levels
of the democratic party and democratic
party politics
uh joaquin castro also of san antonio
represents their district in the united
states house of representatives
and his twin brother julian was barack
obama's housing secretary
and a 2020 democratic presidential
candidate julian castro joins me now
um thank you so much for coming on the
show first off
so sorry for your loss uh you and your
brother joaquin lost your stepmother in
july i believe as cases
were setting new records in texas tell
us about her and what she meant to your
family
yeah thank you very much for your
condolences
my stepmom alice was a wonderful woman
she and my father had been married for
31 years
uh when my father and alice got married
my brother and i were teenagers and so
as teenagers you always wonder
what your step parent you know is gonna
be like
and you worry but she was so wonderful
always very supportive
uh of us her stepsons of her own
children
um of my father she worked for years
in one of the local public school
districts as a cafeteria worker
moved moved her way up to supervisor in
the cafeteria
she had been retired for a number of
years enjoying life with my dad
and on the day that my father turned 80
he drove uh alice who was feeling under
the weather
for the hospital and uh that was the
last time he saw her
she was there for just over three weeks
and
got progressively worse with covet 19
and then lost her life
and you mentioned your parents were
married for 31 years
and then your father developed covert 19
as well but thankfully was able to
recover
what was it like for you this year to to
lose your stepmother
almost lose your father too what goes
through your mind at a time like this
especially
in a place like texas where there are a
lot of people unfortunately in a state
like texas where
who are still you know what do you want
to call them covert skeptical
covert deniers i don't know but when
you've experienced the year you've
experienced what goes through your mind
that it can affect anybody as you said
it doesn't discriminate
uh it doesn't only affect people who are
in the headlines but also
so many folks out there in everyday
walks of life
now i think up to 335 000 americans
it also really drives home the point of
how serious a virus this is
and why people need to take precautions
and it makes you frustrated
even infuriated sometimes with these
political leaders
that instead of doing the right thing
and encouraging people to wear a mask
and uh to practice social distancing
and putting in place sensible measures
to keep people safe
putting public health above politics
they choose the politics and they choose
their own political career
that part has been very frustrating to
watch and
i know that there are a lot of families
out there who of course they can't
bring their loved one back but i think
it provides some solace
knowing that we're about to turn the
corner with
leadership that actually takes this
virus seriously
because that's the least that we can do
uh in the name of so many people
that we've lost
one of those infuriating political
leaders is from your home state of texas
uh texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
who infamously said in april
there are more important things than
living saying the economy for his
children his grandchildren
was more important a pretty awful take
has that mentality
changed at all in texas and if not what
will it take to change it
i wish that i could say it has um
unfortunately dan patrick our lieutenant
governor
is a prime example of uh irresponsible
public servant of an irresponsible
public servant who has put
ideology in politics above the public
health
and done so with you know this devil may
care
nonsensical attitude about things
unfortunately
because of that thousands of texans have
lost their lives that didn't have to
because the lieutenant governor the
governor others in the state have not
addressed this virus the way that it
should have been addressed
and texas is right up there in terms of
the highest number of infections
deaths hospitalizations we're seeing a
surge in my hometown right now
of san antonio uh and so i think that
you know things are going to get worse
before they get better
yeah and you mentioned uh this should
have been done differently
you're a policy guy you worked with joe
biden in the obama administration
what's the single most important thing
he should be trying to do to reduce
covert deaths when he comes into office
in just a few weeks time
i've been very encouraged look he said
clearly that he is
going to require the wearing a mask
where he can
whether that's in airports or other uh
federal facilities
uh he's also encouraged americans to
wear masks
to take this virus seriously that right
there is going to make a world of
difference
compared to what donald trump has done
and basically suggesting you know just
go on about your life and you know you
don't have to take this as seriously
as you should in addition to that we
know right now that
um operation warp speed that is out
there trying to get the vaccine
distributed they'd said that they were
going to get about 20 million doses of
that vaccine
out to the american public by the first
of the year
they're failing miserably at that right
now i think they've only got just over 3
million
distributed joe biden is very
focused on making sure that we actually
have effective
swift vaccine distribution that right
now perhaps is the best most effective
thing that he can be focused on
and thankfully like a responsible public
servant should be
he is focused on it yes
let's hope so because otherwise we're in
real trouble for the rest of 2021 as
well
julian castro thank you so much for
coming on the show our condolences
again to you and joaquin castro on your
loss this year we appreciate you taking
time out
coming up stories of love and loss
married couples that spent their lives
together who were both
claimed by the ravages of the
coronavirus will speak to a daughter
whose parents both died of covid just
moments apart
[Music]
for some families covert 19 has meant
losing
not just one parent but both of them
paul blackwell and rosemary blackwell
were married for 30 years
the school teachers died just minutes
apart holding hands
at a hospital in fort worth texas after
contracting the virus
before thanksgiving mel and sue oars
shared the same icu room
at a hospital in minnesota they were
married six decades and raised five kids
leslie and patricia mcwaters were
married for 47 years
and inseparable from the day they met
they died from covid
not just on the same day but literally
within the same minute
last month in michigan one of their
daughters joanna sisk
joins me now joanna first off our
deepest condolences for your
loss such a big loss and your parents
were so close
in death and so close in life too
weren't they tell us about how they
lived and what they meant to all of you
they lived hand in hand at all times
um with vibrancy just
of um a great deal of zest for life for
people um they had so much love in them
both of them and they shared it with
anybody that wanted to share with them
and even if they didn't
you ended up liking them by the time you
walked away from them they were strong
and amazing
yeah yeah just really um
it's really broken our entire community
really and
and it spans out um a long long ways as
they had friends
everywhere across this country
such a loss to you and your family and
your community clearly and you were
preparing
for your mother to pass away i believe
holding her hand as her breathing slowed
when you were called
suddenly to prepare for your father
passing um and part of the reason why
you were able to be in the hospital
was because you'd survived covert
yourself uh it's just uh
astonishing and such a sad story so you
were with your father when he died but
you couldn't be with your mother as well
um actually they pulled me out of my
mom's room
um and i was holding her hand
and and watching her chest slow you know
slow down drastically
when they did burst into the room and
and told me that my father had coded and
that i needed to go down there but
they were giving him chest compressions
so they
would not let me in the room with him so
i actually was
looking through the glass as he
i guess was already gone as well and
when i went back to my mother's room i
didn't even know that she had passed
when i i got
down there so it was um doubly
devastating
ah doubly devastating indeed i can't
think of how devastating that must have
been for you i'm so sorry
for your double loss uh and your mother
i believe was a nurse
uh as a nurse i'm assuming she took the
coronavirus seriously and even still
she lost her life to this disease it's
the holidays uh this is a tragedy that
makes us want to see our families
defy the guidelines for even the best of
reasons the best of intentions
what is your message to those people out
there who still aren't taking this who
still aren't taking this virus seriously
even now
as the death toll approaches 400 000
i definitely feel that people
want to take it seriously i still
maintain
as i have from the beginning that it
really
needs to stop being such a political
bargaining chip
and people need to be on the same page
with one another and support one another
100 percent no matter which direction
you're you're on and
just for the greater good of of all of
us all of the american people and
all around the world really um
protect yourself in the way that you
feel that you need to
and um i've noticed lately that there
are younger people
whose you know lives have been taken as
well and
i you know read about a 13 year old boy
and a 20 year old girl
and it's it's out there
again it doesn't discriminate that's the
biggest thing that all of us i think
have to
have to offer and i just
i just really hope that something is
done
and it's done sooner than later and
you know if if it means wearing a mask
wear a mask if it means
not gathering you know 50 of you at your
christmas
dinner your new year's dinner now or
whatever just please do it
just as a person that has been through
it
um twice as bad as the average person
there's a lot of people out there
that have lost both parents um within
minutes
within hours within days and
it's it's pretty tough to take
and you know as romantic as it sounds
that they that they left together
you know my husband and i discussed it
and we said you know that's
that's the ideal way that we would like
to go also but
it's it's a selfish
thought
joanne i can't imagine what you've been
through this year and i appreciate you
taking time out to speak with us our
deepest condolences again and thank you
so much for sharing your family story
your parents story
when we return i'll talk to two women
who have helped thousands of families
remember loved ones
if you've experienced loss among your
family and friends this year whether
from
covid or from something else you were
robbed
you were robbed of a loved one who is no
longer with you to ring in the new year
you were also robbed of the rituals of
grieving the ways we gather together to
help each other
celebrate a life well lived what has
endured
is the obituary as the los angeles times
and the new york times recently noted
some families are using obits to call
out
lack social distancing and many
americans is refusal to wear masks
to almost beg people to do everything
they can to avoid getting
and spreading the deadly coronavirus
it has been a year of too many
obituaries pages and pages of them
entire front pages of names and special
sections and papers journalists were
reassigned from other beats as more and
more americans
keep dying as newspapers like the rest
of us struggle to put a human face
on the scale of this devastating
nationwide loss
joining me now is linnea crawford senior
writer for legacy.com
she's been a nationally recognized
obituary writer for two decades and
specializes
in memorializing notable people um
lynnea thanks so much for coming on the
show just today i believe
you published a brief obituary for luke
letlow the louisiana congressman elect
who died tuesday of complications from
covert at the age of 41.
what has this year been like for you as
an obituary writer how hard has it been
it's been a hard year it's been a busy
year we
have published about 30 more obituaries
for notable people this year than we did
in 2019.
uh it's a lot of work it's difficult
work often
i wouldn't necessarily say that all of
those 30 are people who
died of covid19 or who we know for sure
died of kobe 19.
but as i'm sure you know there's so many
excess deaths
for covet 19 and other health concerns
this year
yeah and you've also as i say as you
mentioned collected a good deal of data
this year showing
how spikes and covert deaths in new york
wisconsin texas and more
correspond to an increase in obituaries
how has covert 19
made obituary writing different do you
see people
wanting to make the obits of their loved
ones a bit more political
have a bit more of a statement on public
health
we're certainly seeing that yes as well
as writing obituaries for notable people
at legacy we also publish obituaries
online for about a thousand newspapers
across the u.s
so we see a lot of these obituaries we
keep an eye on
what is what's happening in the obituary
world and what we're seeing
is longer obituaries people are telling
stories in those obituaries
and they are making political statements
and as you mentioned earlier uh begging
people to
take the pandemic seriously i could
quote a couple of
obituaries for you of people who made
statements that might be applicable
one woman who died just earlier yes
this woman died just earlier this month
and her obituary includes
the actions and inactions of the united
states government
regarding the kovid 19 virus have caused
grace
mcdonough and thousands of other nursing
home residents to lose their lives to
the covid19 virus
these same residents had successfully
fought and won great battles
against other diseases and conditions
and yet were placed in harm's way during
the pandemic
these frail elderly sick and vulnerable
innocents were not protected by the
government they supported
fought for contributed to and now
depended on
shame on the united states government
and that's an obituary shame on the
united states government so even in
death
uh they are trying to have an impact and
trying to make their you know the
families around them
are trying to make their deaths more
meaningful um
let me ask you this i believe you also
covered uh 911
in terms of obituary writing back in
2009 2001.
what was that like compared to marking
this pandemic where we have a kind of
911 almost every day nowadays
yes covering 911 as an obituary writer
it was it was a grueling time for us
there were so many
people to memorialize online we were
placing tributes online for them as well
as
reviewing uh tributes and comments
submitted by the public it was a lot of
work for a long time we worked a lot of
long days
but there was a definitive end
to that we knew the point at which
we had placed a tribute online for every
person we knew how many people died in
that tragedy and there came a point
several months after the incident when
our work leveled off
and certainly 10 or 11 months after that
incident
our work had had gone largely back to
normal
and that's about where we are now in
terms of the beginning
of the elevated levels of death in the
us due to the pandemic and we we aren't
at the end and
we don't know how many people we will be
memorializing
we don't even know how many people for
sure have died in this pandemic we don't
have
an exact number that makes it
it it makes it a a bigger
and a stranger job i think might be the
word for it it's
it's very hard not to have an end to it
we look forward to
hopefully having an end to that job
sometime in the near future
yeah no i hope i hope we do have an end
to that job i wish i wish
i wish that you're writing fewer obits
in 2021 certainly covert related obits i
think we can all
uh wish that linear crowther thank you
so much for joining us on the show
tonight we appreciate it
human beings are not meant to be alone
depending on
others cooperating with others being
with others are behaviors that improved
our chances of survival as a species
and although the physical threats have
decreased in the modern world
there are emotional benefits to being
connected we are social creatures by our
very nature
so what we've been asked to do in 2020
for our survival
to socially distance to lock down feels
unnatural to most we've had
to find ways to adapt this husband and
wife medical team found a way to take a
moment
to connect even in all of their ppe
a frontline worker after receiving the
first dose of the vaccine in pittsburgh
said she couldn't wait to hug her kids
this young mother had been fearful of
what she might bring home
to her family scouts in different states
created
hug booths as their service projects so
separated families
could feel connected again safely
and especially in our moments of grief
we long for community around us
for far too many in the pandemic that
hasn't been possible
so one new jersey woman set out to
create create
a community after her own father died
from kovid in april
one that's been helping other mourners
along the way her name is sabila khan
and she joins me now sabina thank you so
much for coming on the show
firstly uh our condolences to you and
your family
uh your family immigrated from pakistan
in the 1980s and your father
shafka who passed away in april i
believe became a pillar in the pakistani
community in jersey city
tell us about him and the role he played
my father was an extraordinary man he
was 76 years old
father of three grandfather of seven the
devoted husband to
my mom for what would have been 50 years
in october
and he was he always showed up for the
pakistani immigrant community in
particular in new jersey he started a
non-profit organization
called pakistanis for america in 2001
with the intent to increase the voter
registration
um among the pakistani community and get
them more interested
in voting um and then 9 11 happened
and he pivoted and organized panels
where the many diverse communities of
jersey city could come together
and talk beyond our differences
so i think he was instrumental in
helping my city heal
it's a big loss to your community into
your city how did you learn that your
father had contracted covert and
what happened in the days after he
passed away
so my father was in a short-term rehab
here in jersey city he had parkinson's
disease and he was getting physical
therapy for parkinson's
and um they closed the doors to the
rehab facility on march 11th which was
very very difficult for us as a family
we
were with him every single day when he
was there
but he reassured us that he would be
fine he was
in the best hands possible and we spoke
to him every day
and all of a sudden probably late march
we stopped getting calls from him and
when we called him
he would answer the phone and he
wouldn't say anything
so we were alarmed we weren't getting a
straight answer from the facility
and in a very roundabout way i
discovered that he was congested
and this was on monday april 6th and
i obviously became very worried
and he was eventually on that evening
rushed to the er
because he was having trouble breathing
he was rushed to the er of a hospital
that's
literally three blocks away from us and
because this was during the height of
the pandemic in my
area in jersey city we couldn't be with
him
and what had happened was kovit took his
voice
which is um something that kovit is
doing in senior patients so he had
lost the ability to speak so what
he was it was hell for us as a family it
was hell for him
he spent three days in a war zone of an
er
in jersey city um because they couldn't
find a bed for him and my father was a
teddy bear he
hated the hospital so the idea that he
was there for
during this time is really really
terrible to think about
and he died on the morning of his eighth
day there at the hospital
and after your father's passing you
created a facebook group called covert
19
lost support for family and friends what
led you to turn to facebook and what has
been the response to that so i started
the group
four days after my father passed and
as much as family and friends were
reaching out
and um you know emailing texting
sending over food baskets all i wanted
to do was talk to someone else who was
going through what i was going through
because
it's coveted grief is a different kind
of beast
so i started the group and it's been
honestly
a lifesaver for me during this time
it's uh it we i started it with another
woman
and angelina boya who i connected with
uh in the days following my father's
death her father passed as well a couple
of days after my dad passed
and the response was amazing
people were looking for us the group
didn't exist before we created
it obviously a group like this did not
exist
and i think that given how
divided our nation is
it's just unfortunate that the country
isn't coming together in the way that it
needs to
in order to heal from this sort of
national trauma that we're facing
and i think the group provided that it
provided solace
and comfort and community to a group of
people who
are really traumatized
i think you're doing a great service uh
just we've got 20 seconds left
what is your message to people out there
who are trying to cope on their own with
grief having lost someone
i want people to know that they're not
alone it is so easy to feel isolated
and alone in this grief i want them to
know that
our community exists that they should
find us on facebook
it's become such a beautiful place for
healing
for everyone regardless of of where you
come from what your political religious
beliefs are
kovit doesn't discriminate and our group
doesn't either so i really do want them
to know that we exist
sabila khan thank you for that message
condolences again from all of us here
and thanks so much for joining us
on the show tonight and that's our show
i know at times tonight's show was
emotional difficult to watch so many of
these stories are
heartbreaking many of these deaths were
preventable but we can't afford to
ignore them
or become numb because of the sheer
numbers and the victims of covert
deserve to be remembered
mourned celebrated and look i know
2021 isn't looking so good right now
either one estimate is putting january's
death toll at a hundred thousand
just january alone it's shocking but it
can be avoided
if we pull together as a nation as local
communities
as americans as human beings we have to
do everything in our
power we can beat this we will beat it
we must
beat it so i say have hope
hope is not a denial of reality hope is
a recognition of what is in front of us
the challenges we face but also an
ability to see past them
and work beyond them and so i'll leave
you with these words
from archbishop desmond tutu which i
often lean on
hope is being able to see that there is
light
despite all the darkness i wish you hope
i wish you solidarity i wish you a very
happy new year
good night
hi i'm mehdi hassan thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching